six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty why don't we go to the 301
area code that's a less frequent area
code for calls for us caller from 301
tell us your name where you're calling
from and what's on your mind today okay
I'm calling from Maryland yes I am okay
great what's on your mind
so I don't know but Cod recently said
that he thinks that he Nazis attract
young boy is because of their outfits
and that they look cool and I just saw a
tweet from James to-morn saying that the
names that the KKK uses like the Grand
Wizard is cool and I keep I keep seeing
these like comments online of I guess
men who say that the KKK Nazis attract
young boys because of the way they're
dressed or the names they use or
something like that and I mean I'm a
girl so I wouldn't know but I just think
it sounds them I know you good this I
know you guys are young it's tough to
talk about this without appearing to
sort of like be offensive against some
people but yeah I mean to me Grand
Wizard sounds absolutely idiotic right I
mean who cares if you're a Grand Wizard
or whatever and for me the outfits are
ridiculous who yesenia who was it that
for you've said at the beginning says
that the the nazi uniforms are cool I
don't have a card oh sorry yeah that's
right that's right I've gotten other
reports that Karl Benjamin who goes by
Sargon of Akkad is saying that listen
I'm not saying that they're wrong I
think that there is a common denominator
that would like the idea of this
structured hierarchical membership
Society where your uniform is expected
to be kept pressed and whatever and it
might be people who would otherwise be
in the military because they like that
structured discipline aspect but for
whatever reason couldn't cut it but at
the same time we heard from former
neo-nazis like Frank mink
and Scott Shepard who is a KKK member
that there is also specific outreach
done by white nationalist groups to
military veterans because they believe
that they're already sort of predisposed
to be more into the structure of some of
these groups so I don't think it's wrong
it doesn't appeal to me I think it's
absolutely idiotic but I think you
seniya is right in what she's heard it
does sound like the Boy Scouts or maybe
one of those games where you level up
like yeah come on or totally thing but
it could also just work backwards to
where these KKK members and neo-nazis
are childish and that's why they appeal
to the boys yeah well that's a whole
yeah right so it could be reverse
causality but yeah I mean I think I I
hate to say it but I think they're right
Yesenia although I think it only appeals
to only a tiny portion of all young men
are even going to be in the universe of
people who would consider joining one of
these groups so it's really like a niche
thing but I think to some extent that
does have an appeal I quite frankly
think that the whole uniform thing is
horrible right I mean I think it's the
opposite of sort of individual
expression and individuality it's this
homogeneous ation that to me is is it's
probably part of the reason why I was
never interested with the exception of
about three weeks where I I don't know
what I was thinking and joining the
military
yeah if some young males go for that
absolutely all right you sending up
thanks for the call very much appreciate
hearing from you we will take calls
again and when we do the number will be
six one seven eight three zero
4750 we'll take a break and be back
after this